وفي رساله موجهه الى روسيا انطلقت تدريبات
لحلف شمال الاطلسي بتنسيق من المانيا
والتي تعد من اكبر المناورات الجويه في
تاريخ الناتو وتستمر حتى الثالث والعشرين
من يونيو
وتهدف المناورات الى اظهار وحده الاعضاء
في مواجهه اي تهديدات محتمله حيث ستشارك
قرابه 250 طائره عسكريه من 25 دوله عضوا
في الحلف او شريكه له بما فيها اليابان
والسويد الدول المرشحه لعضويه النيتو
اضافه الى مشاركه ويصل من عشره الاف جندي
في هذه التدريبات خصوصا من المانيا وايضا
من جمهوريه التشيك واستونيا ولاتفيا كما
وستعزز هذه التدريبات توافقيه التشغيل
والحمايه من الطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ
كروس في حال وقوع هجوم على مدن او مطارات
او موانئ واقعه على اراضي دول الحلف
على كل ماء من برلين مزيد من المتابع حول
هذا الموضوع مراسله العربيه راغده اهلا
وسهلا بك اي رسائل تحميلها هذه المناورات
الاضخم في تاريخ الناتو وهل روسيا هي
المستهدفه مباشره يعني ما في يعني ما في
قفازات هذه موجهه الى روسيا
اهلا بك بالطبع يعني ولكن قاده النيتو
والزعماء الالمان يعني القاده العسكريين
الالمان الذين يقضون هذه العمليه كانوا
حريصين على القول بانه ليست روسيا هي
المستهدفه ولكن السفيره الامريكيه في
برلين قبل يومين عندما كانت تتحدث عن
المشاركه الامريكيه في هذه المناوره كانت
واضحه بان هذه رساله لكل من يريد ان يرى
كما قالت وسمى التحديدا من بين هؤلاء
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لذلك من دون
شك رساله موجهه لروسيا رغم انه هذه
العمليه يعني تم الاتفاق عليها ويتم
التحضير لها منذ قرابه الاربع سنوات يعني
قبل ان تبدا العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ولكن منذ ان بدات هذه العمليه الروسيه
بطبيعه الحال يعني كل خلفيه هذه التدريبات
الان باتت مختلفه ولكن سمعنا اليوم صباحا
ايضا من الجنرال الالماني الذي يقود هذه
العمليه بانه سيكون هناك محاوله او يعني
محاوله لتجنب اي تصعيد من او يعني توجيه
رسالات تعتبرها روسيا بانها ربما
استفزازيه قال بانه الطائرات لن يعني
تتوجه لن تكون باتجاه كلينينجراد التي هي
محاذيه يعني لالمانيا هي تقع بين ليتوانيا
وبولندا ولذلك ستتفادى هذه القوات ان
تتوجه فوق هذه المنطقه تفاديا لاستفزاز
روسيا ولكن من دون شك يعني مشاركه 25 دوله
مشاركه هذه المشاركه الامريكيه الكبيره
جدا ربما هي بمفردها يعني دلاله كبيره
لانه من اصل 250 مقاتله الولايات المتحده
لوحدها ارسلت مئه مقاتله منها وهذا يعني
بانه بالطبع اوروبا ما زالت تعتمد على
الولايات المتحده في امنها والولايات
المتحده من جهتها ايضا تريد ان ترسل رساله
بانها ملتزمه بامن اوروبا راقده في الاونه
الاخيره كثر الكلام عن امكانيه انه من
السيناريوهات المقبله لحلف الناتو من
الاوراق ارسال قوات من دول اعضاء فيه على
الارض هل هنالك حديث جدي خلال هذه
المناورات عن امكانيه ارسال عديد من قوات
النيتو الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه للمشاركه
في هذا القتال ام لا هذا مستبعد تماما
[موسيقى]
يعني هذه هي التدريبات تعمل على مواجهه
سيناريو رسمته يعني قاده ترسمه قاده
الناتو بانه هناك اعتداء او عمليه تنظمها
قوات غريبه على الشواطئ الالمانيه محاكاه
لهجوم على الشواطئ الالمانيه تحديدا على
مرفا رستم على بحر البلطيق ليس هناك اي
ذكر لاوكرانيا ليس هناك اي ذكر بالاسم
باستثناء ما تحدثت به السفير الامريكيه عن
روسيا حتى ولكن يعني هذه هذه الاستعدادات
الكبيره بالطبع هي تحاكي
ربما هجوم محتمل تعد له قوات النيتو ابعد
من اوكرانيا على اراضي بولندا على اراضي
المانيا التي دائما هي يعني المانيا
تحديدا تتعرض لتهديدات من قبل المسؤولين
السياسيين الروس بانه في حال تخطيتهم
الخطوط الحمر فانه دوركم سياتي لذلك هو
ايضا امتحان لالمانيا لانه المانيا تعلم
بانه في السنوات الماضيه خاصه تحت اداره
ترامب كان هناك وطلبات لها بان تكون اكثر
ملتزمه بان تزيد من دفاعاتها انفاقها
الدفاع بين قوات النيتو وموقعها الجغرافي
بطبيعه الحال وسط اوروبا يجعلها يعني ربما
المرشح الافضل ان تستقبل هذه التدريبات
العربيه راغده برنامج شكرا جزيلا لك راقده
على كل هذه المتابعه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات